SINGAPORE AND PHILIPPINES HAVE
ALSO PROPOSED LAWS TO RESTRICT
FAKE NEWS.
BACK HERE AT HOME, REPUBLICANS
ARE HOPING TO PICK UP A U.S.
SENATE SEAT THIS FALL AND
WEST VIRGINIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON EASILY IN
2016 THEY ARE BUT THE G.O.P.
PRIMARY THEIR MIND TO NOT
PRODUCE THE MOST DELECTABLE
OPPONENT AGAINST DEMOCRAT
INCUMBENT JOE MANCHIN.
PETER DOOCY HAS A STORY TONIGHT
FROM CHARLESTON, WEST VIRGINIA.
>> THE RACE TO REPLACE ONE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS IN
THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN UPENDED BY
PRIMARY CANDIDATE WITH A
PROBATION OFFICER.
THAT CANDIDATE WITH A CRIMINAL
RECORD IS DON BLANKENSHIP, THE
FORMER CEO OF THE MASSEY
ENERGY COMPANY IS WELL KNOWN IN
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER T
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER I
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER G
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER ,
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER A
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER C
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER N
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER I
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER T
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER O
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER N
WEST VIRGINIA FOR, AMONG OTHER A
MISDEMEANOR CHARGE OF CONSPIRING
TO VIOLATE FEDERAL MINE SAFETY
STANDARDS.
FOLLOWING AN EXPLOSION AT THE
UPPER BIG BRANCH MINE THAT
KILLED 29.
HE THINKS IT GIVES HIM A LEG UP.
>> THAT WAS A POINT FOR COAL
INDUSTRY AND WEST VIRGINIA
CONSERVATIVE POLITICS.
HE PROBABLY DOESN'T SURPRISE
HIS PEOPLE WOULD COME AFTER ME
AND THEY DID.
>> HE MAKES THEM A PRIMARY A
THREE-WAY CONTEST WITH
CONGRESSMAN EVAN JENKINS IN THE
STATE'S ATTORNEY GENERAL PATRICK
MORRISEY.
THE WINNER FACES INCUMBENT
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
WHO DECLINED TO BE INTERVIEWED
FOR THIS STORY.
IN A STATE PRESIDENT TRUMP WON
BY 42 PERCENTAGE POINTS OR 2016.
INSPIRING GOVERNOR JIM JUSTICE
TO JUMP SHIP FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> I WILL BE CHANGING MY
REGISTRATION TO REPUBLICAN!
>> NOW THE AG IS TRYING TO
DISCREDIT ONE OF HIS OPPONENTS
FOR HIS PAST AFFILIATION AS A
DEMOCRAT.
>> I THINK EVAN JENKINS IS
LIBERAL.
>> JENKINS, THE CONGRESSMAN, IS
USING MORRISSEY'S PAST HISTORY
IN THE GARDEN STATE AGAINST HIM.
>> THE OTHER CANDIDATE AS A
PERSON WHO RAN FOR CONGRESS AND
THE
THE YEAR 2000 ON A THEME THAT HE
WAS JERSEY THROUGH AND THROUGH.
>> THEY PUT A PREMIUM ON
PORTRAYING A PROXIMITY TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE AGENCIES TO
ROLL BACK SOME OF THOSE
EGREGIOUS, THOSE BURDENSOME
REGULATIONS.
>> I'M THE ONLY CANDIDATE WHO
ACTUALLY HAS AN ESTABLISHED
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> AS FOR BLANKENSHIP, HE'S
TYPING A STATUS AS A POLITICAL
NEWCOMER.
HE INSISTS THIS CAMPAIGN IS NOT
AN ATTEMPT, YET EVEN WITH JOE
MANCHIN, WHO WAS GOVERNOR DURING
THE DISASTER AND LATER SAID
BLANKENSHIP HAS BLOOD ON HIS
HANDS.
>> SENATOR MANCHIN NEEDS TO BE
DEFEATED FOR THE SAKE OF
WEST VIRGINIA.
SPEAK OF THE DAY AFTER TOMORROW,
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS COMING TO
WEST VIRGINIA FOR A ROUNDTABLE
ABOUT JOBS, ATTORNEY GENERAL
MARCY AND CONGRESSMAN JENKINS
HAVE ALSO BEEN INVITED IN
THEIR OFFICIAL CAPACITIES.
WE DON'T KNOW IF AN ENDORSEMENT
IS IMMINENT.
JENKINS TELLS ME ANY KIND WORDS
FROM THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF